[Music]
so what type of
thoughts and feelings you have when you
see other female breasts these shoes
they're cute yeah they're nice I feel
like James Bond are like uh so I've been
drinking a whiskey on the Rocks okay
so you don't do that you're like hey
babe
[Music]
nice to meet you you better give me a
cheat kiss okay you want a chicken I do
I do I'm not gonna lie what's your name
Aisha Aisha I like your outfit you did
yeah where are you from I'm from South
London South London and you got the nose
piercing yeah is that an issue that's
not an issue but I have uh what are your
beliefs on pride month on pride month
well
um
I'm I'm full I'm definitely for oh
things to do right if unless that
offends you like I I love Pride I'm a
very proud person yeah no I mean like
gay people bisexual trans yeah I love
everybody you love everybody yeah I
believe in love speech that we should
love everyone I appreciate that yeah I
appreciate it are you one of the are you
on the alphabet
maybe what does that mean like you're
probably on the Queue probably on the
Queue what does that mean queer so like
I'm not for or against anything I'm just
curious like I don't mind
you know that used to be an insult yes
you're a queer and now I guess it's like
reclaimed I guess okay you know how like
the n-word was reclaimed for the black
people I guess it's not the same way at
all but I'm get I'm saying it's like
it's reclaimed in that sense so you're
like I'm not you're the n-word of the
alphabet people no I don't really want
to say no no I meant like the a
derogatory term has been reclaimed
they I'm pretty sure they still get
upset about that in America that there's
all these yeah they'll beat the dog poop
out of some if a white lady says it
you'll see all these teenagers in
Chicago
really yeah
no no no that's not like here like I
guess if someone calls you queer like
it's not an insult well I'm sorry about
the N word oh the N word yeah no no no
it's a problem here as well you could
that would yeah no no no it's a problem
here I was talking about the word queer
so if I say that it's not an insult no
oh okay you're queer yeah I don't find
that offensive okay queer
it still doesn't feel offensive like
queer
even when I squint and do it yeah but
like you you're not saying it in terms
of evil like you kind of look cute
okay let me try to say it
queer
I guess I'm not offended
that's good no you don't you don't get
that triggered
you know that there was a girl that came
in earlier and she said that this show
is problematic and she's seen some of
myself which said it's problematic and
so that she stormed out bumped her purse
on me and left
um do you find what do you find
problematic
I guess if I'm problematic is when
people
make
um unnecessary comments not
conversations that don't need to be
talked about but like I guess what I
find problematic is when people get to
personal per se or when people are just
like rude for no reason I guess
I guess that's what I find problems for
no reason yeah like I and also
unnecessary hate I find that problematic
like you don't need to hate someone just
love everyone man love everyone yeah
like it's it's not that deep that's
always my it's not that dude we don't
need to be arguing it's not that deep we
can have a conversation about it but why
is there all this animal c yeah there's
a lot of polarization and it's okay to
have polarizing views you're a very
accepting person yeah you don't have a
lot of arguments no what was the last
argument that you had do you remember
probably an actual argument where I got
like heated that's like yeah heated
argument probably like a year ago what
was it about and it it was genuinely
just a drunk argument so it doesn't even
count that counts because what your
drunk feelings are your real feelings no
it was like it was it was genuinely just
like an argument because she this girl
was just
you know when they're just causing
unnecessary problems like I don't like
unnecessary problems like why are you
coming into my safe space and causing
problems like get out of here so what
did it start out like can you go oh she
came she I was at like a little like
motive with my friends was just drinking
having fun or whatever and then um
she just came to genuinely just to bring
problems because she didn't like me and
my friend and I was like there's
actually no there's no point I'm not
doing this and then she just made a big
big big big big big big big
yeah why doesn't she like you she
doesn't like me because I'm friends with
the girl she doesn't like
so it's just it's just it's just Petty
women problems and I don't like it women
women yeah are you non-binary
all kind of woman buyers fully support
non-binary people my friends non-binary
and I love them today that's great yeah
so what makes you think that you're a
queue you're cute oh because I'm I'm
open I'm I'm open like if if I fell in
love with a woman so you've had the
reason yeah
off camera yes no on camera no yeah yeah
so I haven't I haven't had a threesome
that's what Q means you're open to it no
Q means I'm open to loving anyone I
guess that's how I view it like I'm open
to loving whoever I want to love like if
if I fall in love with a woman then I
fall in love a woman if I fall in love
with a man I fall in love with a man if
I fall in love with a non-binary person
I fall in love with a number any person
right but you know what people in love
do yeah they have sex I know threesomes
wow yeah they do they definitely do yeah
okay but you're you're waiting for
marriage
of what uh have sex or have a threesome
to have sex
um we just wish that ask me something
I'm gonna go on rapid fire
um
what can I ask you how many kids do you
want then okay good question
how many can you give me
I don't actually want kids or something
right now
I've listened to my explanation
listen to my destination how old are you
oh I'm 19. you're 19. 18 19 yeah okay 18
19. yeah no I'm 19 next month
okay because you can't be two ages at
one no no I know but I'm in my 19th year
that was the first thing that okay okay
you're in 19 but you're 18. okay yeah so
why don't you but you don't want kids in
the future
I don't I don't like the way this um no
because like that's
I just lied to you they didn't lie to me
it's because if you want kids now you're
now you're trying to tell me that I want
kids that's just natural we all that's
hard yeah of course it's our purpose but
I just feel like uh world and like the
environment that I would be raising kids
in I don't really want to raise kids in
this environment climate change all that
[__] climate change yes that's gonna
affect my when by the time I have kids
you don't want to have a family because
of climate change yes
wow a climate change inflation all these
things like inflation yeah
yeah okay two things the climate is
always changing yeah okay yeah I
understand that but like the dollar and
the pound has always inflated okay yeah
you're correct forever it's always it's
again the climate's gonna continue
changing and the dollar and the pound
that's gonna be in this in its mess like
how much it's increasing and so quickly
in a short period amount of time isn't
normal
so what does that have to do with having
kids because I don't want to bring my
even in the sense of like they lie to
you
this is this this
slave mind this is the programming I've
heard this before from from woke people
they'll say that they don't want to
bring kids into this world because of
but that's not a good enough reason to
not to give up your purpose but I don't
feel like my my only purpose as a woman
is to have kids like of course that's
your highest purpose yeah of course of
course I genuinely believe that that's
what I was manufactured to do to give
kids to but
I was manufactured to give kids or
whatever but um I also feel like there's
more to a woman than giving kids
like what like like I can I can do
whatever I want in this life and not
have kids and still live a fulfilling
life like what like I could have my own
career I could have my own business I
couldn't have what what business is well
personally I do music so I do rap I
don't rap I sing
um personally adding music so that's the
type of thing I enjoy and I don't feel
like until until I'm in a comfortable
enough position to give my kids
everything that they want in life and
everything that they need or guess who
should do that who should do that your
husband my husband your husband should
provide you okay and your singing career
and the kids you don't have to be out
here getting all this money
I could you could but do you really want
to yeah I would love to have my own
money like of course it's beneficial to
have a man who um has his own money and
gives me his money too but
um I have like a complete balance in our
relationship as well if you want an
equal relationship not fully equal but I
want to have my own so like if he left
me tomorrow if he left me tomorrow I
still have my own if I give my all to a
man and have like nothing for myself
when he leaves what am I left with
the focus that you should have is on
maintaining the relationship and keeping
that because you want to know the truth
if he's a complete [__] why should I
want to keep
don't pick an [__] if I
do it sometimes you get into a
relationship that's more important what
women your age should focus on is
picking the right guy that you can have
a long-term relationship with it's not
that hard to let somebody and figure out
what their real character is and also to
not pick a complete loser I think a lot
of girls they focus on their career and
being girl bosses and Q and pride and
then they don't spend enough time
investing into because the truth is guys
don't really leave their girl men don't
really leave relationships it's pretty
much always the girl she's upset about
something she storms off she gets mad
she looks through his phone because he's
cheating but how often do you really
know guys that left that the
relationship is like is going okay and
then he's like he packs his bag and
leaves it's usually the girl but is it
going okay if he's out here seeking
other women
why does that determine whether or not
the relationship is good or bad because
I feel like if you have boundaries in
your relationships if we spoke about
boundaries if we if we're in
relationships but why even have those
boundaries in the first place if we
don't have the boundaries then it's okay
why do you have those boundaries
I don't well no I do have dinner I do
have those boundaries I do have these
boundaries so we're gonna have 10 kids
I'm gonna cheat on you
I'll provide for you you can sing on
Spotify but you you don't need to give
up children to go and sing some songs
it's not that time consuming to sing you
don't need to go and give up your main
purpose yeah but it depends I'm not just
singing It's the whole Artistry first of
all it's not like I'm just singing some
songs wow
no right music is a whole art it's not
just oh I'm gonna just make someone
write my songs and I'm just gonna sing
this microphone it's an art it's not
just singing I put my emotion into it
and my time and my money and you know
we'll give you more emotion to give you
material to sing about
a bad relationship a family
having well love like being emotional
and being in that state yeah of course
and if I find it then hooray my my
feelings have changed but why don't you
apply that same logic to your career why
don't you say like oh because of climate
change and we only have a minute left oh
I was like
basically we only have a minute left but
you seem like a really nice girl
genuinely I think that you're a good
person thank you um and I like you thank
you if there's anything that I can tell
you they're aligned to you about climate
change and about inflation that is a
reason to not have a family is why
things are so polarized and why things
are backwards because it should be our
normal priority
you're not in your head but you're what
are you thinking about I'm not thinking
I'm I'm just I'm listening okay
what would you rate this data on a scale
of one to ten it was infamous
taught me a lot like so I'd rate it in
eight an eight a nine eight yeah nine
eight nine
eight point five eight point five I'll
take it this is great thank you what's
your name again are you sir Aisha one
more kissing machine
bye bye I don't remember her name Aisha
I think it was Aisha she was great she
was I think she's very beautiful and I
would say that was uh my favorite date
so far I this is maybe it's the
mentality you can roast me the comments
but I can fix her I could like she's not
she's not too far gone she has like
enough of a bubbly personality she's
just been that's the perfect example of
a girl who's been indoctrinated by
wokeness this is one of the kids because
of inflation what type of what are you
talking about inflation is a reason to
not have a family I will fix her I can
change her I can make her see because
she has all the the right qualities look
she's talking about I'm a queer it's
like what I knew it as soon as I saw the
nose ring I'm like I know you
I can I'm gonna get it out I'm gonna
unplug all the little Uzi vert piercings
and the maker into a wife I can mold her
I can fix her
I like her so you do
I am a businessman
nice how what's your favorite crypto
[Laughter]
foreign